all right one really funny other thing
related to YouTube channels and then
we're going to move on to a bunch of
other things you may or may not know
that we launched a second or really a
third YouTube channel recently and it is
called Pacman Finance okay this is not a
political Channel this is a channel in
which we do personal finance and a
little light economics so how to uh put
together an asset allocation why is some
inflation good why you shouldn't try to
time the market all these things
so funny initially when we launched the
channel a bunch of right Wingers were
like dude you're a socialist why are you
going to give Financial advice and some
of them have tomato 180 and turned
around I love this this guy Tommy Boy
okay after we posted our first video he
wrote this is comical a complete
socialist talking about asset allocation
laughable hypocrisy now of course I'm
not a socialist but he was entitled to
his opinion the second video we posted
Tommy Boy shows up and he says dude
you're really gonna keep talking out of
both sides of your mouth on two channels
be a capitalist or be a socialist stop
trying to pretend you can be both now
having a budget doesn't exactly make you
one or the other but anyway Tommy Boy is
entitled to his opinion and then just
yesterday Tommy Boy shows up after like
our sixth video
Ben says Pac-Man gives sound
conservative Financial advice on this
channel ignore his utter nonsense
political advice on the other channel
and just watch this channel tommyboy has
been turned around 180 degrees by the
sensible and sound information remember
I'm not giving any individual Financial
advice but the information on the Pacman
Finance Channel I invite you to check it
out youtube.com
pacmanfinance we've got Clips going up
about all sorts of different topics and
if you have a finance topic you would
like me to address not politics folks
different Channel not politics you can
email info davidpackman.com and I will
do my very best to address that and soon
we'll be taking some personal finance
questions for the channel lots of
exciting things coming up all right we
have a fantastic show tonight it is Beto
versus Abbott debate for Texas governor
I will be live on YouTube twitch and
Facebook for that debate I hope you will
join me I don't know exactly what time
it is must be sometime around 7 P.M I
don't know
um and I hope to see everybody then